non-minimalists
i heard you talk about your marriage and
how kovid may have saved it in a way
this all the pandemic the quarantine
yeah saved it yeah may have illuminated
some things you weren't aware of
yes you know i have been a touring comic
for a long time
um and um let's paint that picture what
does that look like
you're on the road how many days a year
how many weeks a year i would tell you
the last
three years in particular i've been
hitting it pretty hard and i would say
anywhere from
40 to 46 weeks wow wow
and so but it seemed
okay if you back it up a little bit what
i've realized more and more the longer
i'm in
hollywood which is one of the reasons
that we're moving
is that no matter how successful you get
you always feel like you need to be on
the wheel
this town keeps you on the wheel oh yeah
it be i i i in this town
combined with social media because
you're constantly looking
at people who have more who are doing
better
that's constantly what you're being
shown you need this is cool
but you shouldn't be satisfied with this
because this is next yeah
and that's right i'm gonna rest next
weekend after i get
this and then you get that and you're
like oh if i work a little harder i get
this
right and this town really keeps people
on the wheel like that it's how they
keep the machine going yeah it's never
enough it's never enough it's never
enough
right so and as a comic
you know or especially early on we work
for chicken fingers
there there's a different comic
mentality which is
i'm going to take this gig because i
don't know if it's going to be the last
gig i ever get yeah
wow it's just that we get we're like i'm
taking this one
i'll rest next weekend so you know how
long the dry years are
and then you know there comes a point in
time in your life where people like i
don't want to see that [ __ ] old dude
you know what i mean so in your brain
you're like i have this finite amount of
time
i am going to go as hard as i can
so i was doing all of these weeks and i
would tell my wife you know but we need
the money
for this you know i just need the money
for this and every gig
and those aren't lies by the way and we
can make up these stories
100 it wasn't like i was saying we we
don't need to save money or we don't
right
but every next gig became the most
important do you know what i mean by
that like
every next gig was like i need we do
need this one because this
yeah and we had gotten used to
an abnormal life being normal we had
gotten used to
being a part and living apart so when
quarantine came
i we neither one of us realized that
that was what was happening to our lives
and we talked about all the time about
how much we love each other and we have
this great relationship and
i think we it was just talking points
and then the first two weeks was like a
honeymoon
no driving thriving and then after those
two weeks it was like hey
when are you gonna leave me the [ __ ]
alone like i'm not used to you being
here
we were you this is both of you saying
this we were used to
so what what she had ended up telling me
was you know when you used to come home
and the kids were young it wasn't
i did not look forward to you coming
home i look forward to seeing you
but we had a flow you upset the apple
cart
every time and then i had to come and
reset that [ __ ]
not that i was coming home and doing
anything bad but i have my energy and
she has hers
and she sets up her house for to have
her flow
when it's just her and the kids which
was a lot of the time
so i would come home and [ __ ] that up
and um
then so my kids are older so we became
empty nesters
and that's when it really became her
life my life and together
when i was home i was back on the wheel
so it wasn't like i was together
in home and present i was doing shows i
was doing gigs i was taking meetings and
she was having her life
and we had just gotten used to that and
so
quarantine made us realize how
unhappy we were wow
b with each other to being
you know what i mean we we were i was
just like yeah you know
i shouldn't be upset with you
when you walk in the room and i'm by
myself
drinking coffee and you sit down you're
like how's it going
i shouldn't be upset that you're in my
space
because we're married like i want to be
with you
but i was so used to being by myself it
was the same thing like
she was upsetting my flow that i set for
myself which is i do what i want during
the day
i don't really have anyone else to it's
not that i'm out with
hookers and coke but like i do what i
want during the day because i'm
by myself and we had to re-learn
how to be together and
figure out if we still liked it and how
did you do that
we what was the process like okay
for me it was putting down my phone
yeah um
you know people tell you all the time
hey you got this social media number's
got to go up content content content
content content
so that's the new care that dangles in
front of your face for
us right and so it was that i was like
put that down
be more present cook dinner together
not that we couldn't weren't going to do
our work and our stuff anymore but like
sets
time apart walk the dog together set
time
even if it's just as small as this is
the show we're going to watch together
or hey we're not going to turn on our
phones until 10. or whatever those
things were
to reconnect and really be like do
are we still compatible because at that
point i don't think either one of us
knew if
if that is what was happening i think a
lot of these questions start to come up
when we start to have these problems and
they manifest in different ways
they may they can manifest in a healthy
way where you start asking each other
these questions like are we still
compatible
or they start to manifest in nitpicking
and rage and passive aggressive behavior
did you notice any of that yes early on
and i also noticed
in recently and i i can tell you
recently and one of the reasons i'm glad
i turned off my phone is i could feel
myself recently
both of us sliding back down into that
wheel
like the last three weeks and things get
tense in our house
we're a little shorter with each other
we're um we we're
when i see us downstairs in the morning
and i'm drinking a coffee and she's
drinking a tea and i'm in the living
room and she's in the dining room and
we're both on our phones
i'm like oh yeah we're back we're back
into
the being those people and so i
definitely feel a slip sliding back in
every now and then
but the nit picking and the jumping on
each other
a lot yeah a lot and here's the thing
she is a very vocal person she likes to
talk it out
guess who doesn't you know what i like
to do let's just be
let's just figure it out as we go i
don't want to talk about it every day
i really don't want to talk i just want
to learn how to do it
yeah but she's like this is how we're
going to learn how to do it right
we're going to learn how to do it by
talking about it right
you kind of need a direction right and
it sounds to me like that's what she's
she's saying is yeah we need to identify
what
what direction in which we're traveling
uh and you're like i just want to travel
yes she wants us to be like hey if we
have this schedule like from here to
here this one work this is how we're
going to do this
we're going to do from 10 to 11 no phone
we're going to talk you know we're going
to just look at each other we're going
to take a walk or whatever we're going
to do
and i want to be like hey let's just
wake up in the morning
with this is how we know we're supposed
to do it and she's like yeah but we
don't
do that we don't do that we just slide
into what we know best right which is
work
work work